دع رئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي دول
الخليج الى عدم السماح بالتاثير على علاقه
مع مصر بسبب ما تورده الافلام ومواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وخلال مشاركته في
الجلسه الرئيسيه بالقمه العالميه الحكومات
في دبي قال الرئيس المصري انه لولا وقوف
الاشقاء في الامارات والسعوديه والكويت
لما كانت مصر قادره على تجاوز اسبتها
اذا
باكده هنا ان لولا وقوف الاشقاء
في الامارات في السعوديه في الكويت اللي
انا بتكلم عليه لولاه
ما كانتش مصر وقفت تاني خليني اوجه لكم
الشكر تاني وتالت ورابع وما تسمحوش
[موسيقى]
ما تسمحوش للاقلام
والافكار ومواقع التواصل المغرضه انها
تؤثر على الاخوه اللي بينا
بيننا كلنا
واقل رئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي ده حاله
الياس التي يواجهها المصريون منذ سنه
2011 شكرت تحديا رئيسيا امام مصر على
امتداد السنوات اضاف رئيس المصريه
الاطرافا داخليه مصريه لم يسميها توقعتها
ان دوله ستسقط وانها ستؤول اليها
التحدي الاولاني بعد 2011 هو حاله التشرذم
والتفكك وفقد الامل والياس اللي كان
بيعاني منها المصريين
[موسيقى]
ودي حاله مش بس وليدة 2011 ده منهج اتعمل
على مصر من ناس جوه مصر بفكر معين
عشان يعني
متهيا لهم ان الدوله لما تقع هتبقى في
ايديهم
ما يعرفوش يعني ايه دوله لان الدوله لما
تقع ما بترجعش تاني